hi good morning everyone yeah I'm Irina
just in case you got the room wrong this
is about computer vision and deep
learning and give it a sick
okay so yeah good morning
right so what's this talk about actually
so let's say you you're in a team who's
building an app where they want to apply
some special effects or filters to
people so they for instance on a phone
right so you're taking a video of
someone and you want fire to appear on
top of them or they hold their hand like
this and they want some flame on top of
their hand or yeah or maybe on the
hololens because you're building some
augmented reality experience and they
find out that but they'll be going UTV's
they'll be using unity right and they
find that there's this nice plug-in from
OpenCV which is like the computer vision
choice knife there's a plugin for unity
and the question is is this enough is
this good enough for us
or maybe you're building an app where
you want the user to be maybe scrolling
through their Instagram feed and they
see some influence who are wearing some
nice clothes and they want to know where
exactly to buy them so will computer
vision take you far enough for that or
maybe you join a lab that has been doing
tumor segmentation for a while and
they're asking does it make sense to
drop traditional techniques and start
introducing deep learning to carry on
segmenting tumors better and better so
there are several different applications
where the question is always well we
already have a method here is is it
enough or should we start building a
deep learning pipeline to to improve
what we have when does it make sense so
yeah this is for instance the kind of
effects I was talking about this would
be the kind of thing that in a platform
like a hololens or or a phone you would
like to see so you would be detecting
someone and fires and particles come out
of their mouth or hand whatever but
we'll be looking at that at that case a
bit later so maybe you know this guy
at least if anyone's ever downloaded
amnesty MMS dataset the name will be
familiar otherwise he's a founder
of facebook' I research group and yeah
let that soak in for a minute because
it's been six years since 2012 and you
already have people talking about yeah
how computer vision is outdated and
actually yesterday at the social event I
don't know if he's in the room right now
but there was this person saying well I
did some computer vision in University
and that was around 2012 and it's
amazing how everything that I did is
actually obsolete well that may be a
stretch because sure deep learning has
big has become a revolution and some of
and many of the people deeply care about
it for instance who cares about this
well people like me so I'm a computer
vision engineer and I've been doing this
say an applied research at inria for
anyone who knows that I've been working
in medtechs
I don't know why but it makes me super
happy to have it to have done it in
three different countries and I've been
doing it at startups for consumer apps
and now it's seamless mobility so
there's a whole ecosystem of people that
really care about whether it's
completely obsolete what we've been
doing for the last ten years well
actually for the last 20 years and
whether we should all be just diving
into deep learning which is a fair
question but then the other question is
what exactly do we mean so what is
computer vision anyway and that is up
for debate but this is kind of a
description that I I feel comfortable
with so computer vision would be would
be an applied field where you take
techniques from different from different
areas for instance we want to extract
features using image processing
techniques and with this if you've ever
heard about safe descriptors or hogg
that's what I would be talking about and
we use machine learning techniques to
extract meaning from those features
because the one gives us machine
friendly machine friendly
interpretations or representations of
the images and machine learning gives us
techniques to understand what's going on
with them
to detect things to interpret them to
understand scenes for instance and one
of those techniques inside machine
learning is steep learning it's just one
more tool and it's worth knowing the
tools you have and when to apply them so
one huge difference between between both
fields is where exactly do you encode
the domain knowledge in the case of
traditional computer vision you will
encode it in the code that's where you
know what you're going to be expecting
so you code already planning for those
cases whereas in deep learning for
instance you trust that you're choosing
the right dataset to train that's why
you want a huge diverse data set to be
ready for anything and that's where you
encode that I may know that you have so
in case you you're in a hurry spoiler
alert if you take one thing and one
thing only or actually two things from
from this talk it's this always always
have a baseline and we'll talk about
what that baseline can be and be sure to
go through iterations of designing
tweaking and evaluating in both that
baseline and the and your and your deep
learning or newer computer vision
approaches so it so the it's those two
things that you need to remember you
need to know where you're starting from
that baseline and you need to go through
iterations where you're very careful
about reproducibility about knowing
exactly how you how your what your
hypothesis is and how exactly you're
going to be measuring it right
so when yeah the big question and
basically it's about constraint
it's an eliminating game if you will
receive your constraints that usually
deal with data or the hardware you're
going to be training on or deployment
and when you start looking at those
constraints hopefully or sometimes not
so luckily some of those approaches get
discarded so sometimes applying
traditional techniques just isn't going
to get you anywhere and sometimes a fine
deep learning is just not feasible
so what kind of things are you going to
looking at we always start with the data
right this still is a data-driven
approach so what exactly what is your
data how complex is it are you going to
be deploying your product in the wild
and in the world with in the world I
mean are you if you're going to be
detecting faces are you all your
subjects like the woman here nicely
sitting in the middle of a frame facing
the camera white background extremely
easy even if your baseline was just a
dummy dummy module that kept returning
center of the of the frame as the center
of the face you do pretty well and that
would be a baseline right just returning
yet center of the image that's where the
face is BAM finished okay but most of
the times that's not going to be the
case especially if you're going to be
using a product I don't know in a bar
with everything blurry or in for
instance in that with that fire fire
dancer where they're moving all over the
place
yeah just trying to to find something
right in the middle of the frame or or
with maybe just a thread holding maybe
it won't help now maybe some of you
where were here on Friday at the Luigi
workshop where this particular example
was given the bananas versus limit and
he gave an excellent example of a
baseline where he was saying okay we can
assume that home lemons are going to be
circles right so we apply a half
transform and we detect circles in an
image if there's a circle it's a lemon
if it's not it's a banana okay and it
takes you it takes you far enough so
what happens when you get wonky images
or when those lemons and those bananas
appear all over the place
well that's closer to the definition of
in the world and yet another problem is
how much data do you have and what's its
nature because if it's RGB then well
you're in luck because after all there's
pre trained models with imagenet so you
won't all that talk about needing
millions and millions of images well
it's kind of already been solved for you
because there's pre trained models over
those millions
millions of similar images but as soon
as your use case deviates from that one
if you're not dealing with RGB or if
your RGB it's still RGB but it's a
completely different field yeah maybe
you will need some new data and
increasing numbers of it but the big
question that you will always be asked
is okay how much is enough and for that
yeah I'm sorry but it still it depends
it depends on the complexity of your
data if you want rules of thumb I don't
know you can take a look at common data
sets like image net or cocoa or Pascal
how many how many samples do you have
from each class and at the very least
you see the image net M is off it gives
you 600 samples per class okay is that
good enough for you I don't know and
it's not too much I don't know if this
yesterday morning we had a talk about
few short learning where only a few
samples were being used so it also
depends on the technique but a good rule
of thumb is if you're really starting
from a computer vision to a traditional
approach chances are you're not in a
situation where you can handle very few
samples in a deep learning field in a
deep learning approach and two last
considerations it's hard we're not just
for training because for training of
course you're going to be needing a GPU
but that can also be said for other
machine learning approaches it's always
going to be quicker if you're using a
GPU right so that's not the question
but it's mostly deployment because are
you where are you going to be deploying
well if you go into if you're going to
be using AWS or TCP if you're going to
be deploying using GPUs well not that it
might make sense but you can I guess and
that's gonna come into your problem you
you have a limited resources if you're
going to be using a p3 instance knock
yourself out but what if you want to
deploy in a hololens or on a chassis
vibe or or Apple or or phone or a camera
there's many smart cameras that only
have CPUs so what will you do then some
huge models just won't fit there and
it's very easy as an engineer
researcher it's really easy to go okay
I'm I did my survey I know the best sick
detector out there and I'm just going to
build it and I'm done
great I've implemented it and then
whoever's going to deploy it goes this
doesn't fit in the memory dude we only
have a CPU and we only have or maybe I
only have a phone and we only have I
don't know 50 megabytes of RAM available
to us that's not going to that's not
going to work and more than that what
are you going to be using to deploy what
libraries because as much as tensorflow
is very flexible both for you've got
tensorflow light for four phones
you've got and you can serve it on
service of course but if you want to use
an iPhone or again that hololens and you
want to deploy using say core ml well as
much as onyx is a fantastic format it's
still ongoing work so there are types of
layers that are not supported so what
will you do then you try to build your
your segmentation model your detection
model or whatever and some of the layers
that you're using just aren't there so
either you implement them yourself or
you're out of luck so these are the kind
of considerations you need to think
about okay so you've got that in the
back of your mind but you thought okay
I'm going to I'm going to dive into it
so how does one start with this and
again this I'm going to go back to the
idea for baseline you need to know where
you're starting from even if it's a
really lousy baseline even if you say
well random guess or again the example
from before I'm trying to detect a phase
I'm going to say center of the frame is
where the face is always always Center
and well it's maybe a bad baseline but
it's one and to get a baseline actually
it's not just saying okay this approach
is going to me my control you also need
to say how am I going to make sure I'm
doing something better
how what number are you going to put
onto it what is your priority is it
speed or is it some form of accuracy
define that accuracy
actually do you care about your
false-positive do you care more about
your false negatives what what's in
there
and but more more than that you need to
know okay in this domain or in this task
that I'm going to implement how do I
know I'm doing better and for that you
need to know the task and the task is
essentially the translation between what
your user tells you they want and what
machine learning or computer vision
program you're really solving so let me
give you a few examples of this isn't
quite clear these two applications seem
very different right one of them is in
the is in a medical environment achill
domain where you'd be just telling
someone if if they have a melanoma or if
they have a mole okay the other can be a
consumer app where they automatically
tag your pictures before you upload them
oh hey you've been taking a picture of
your sunset a beach and you can then say
say let's retrieve all of those images
about beaches and and sunset they're
apparently very different but under the
hood they are still just a
classification problem so you're
probably going to be measuring them
exactly the same way and in this case oh
well we won't be seeing the video but in
this case oh there you go
so let's say for instance these three
examples the one on top
Apple pays Apple and other brands to be
fair tons and tons of money to be right
there in the middle of many frames and
films there that's there there that's
our branding it's it's called product
placement and of course if they've paid
a ton of money to a producer to include
their their their products everywhere
they want to make sure and years and
years ago they would have some person
sitting through hours of footage seeing
how many minutes of the logo was in
there we don't have to you can just
detect where the logo is at the same
time you could be just detecting
pedestrians to allow a car or a train or
whatever to stop automatically we
thought the driver having to do it
that's also detection
and the video you're seeing or you've
just seen is another example of
detection where all you need to do is
detect where the hand is and place the
special effect on it that's also
detection so it's three very different
use cases but under the hood they are
the same task and likely when you're
measuring how good you how well you're
doing you're going to be using the same
metrics last example segmentation tumor
segmentation has nothing to do with oh
hey where's what what clothes do I have
here let's segment out that segment that
so I can then send that part of the
image to some recognition system or to
some some query to retrieve things there
are very different use cases apparently
but at the at the end of the day you
want the outline of a type you want the
outline of shirts or you want the
outline of a tumor so again same same
task under the hood same ways of
evaluating it probably whoops so once
you have your task you choose a metric
to evaluate how well you're doing and
these are just examples and I'll go
fairly quickly around this but yeah
basically you can for instance for
things like classification you can
choose you could say accuracy users or
managers usually talk about accuracy but
they're usually not thinking what do I
care most about so take your pick do you
prefer to measure with f1 do you prefer
your position you recall this there's a
ton of metrics out there choose one
choose what you care for same thing
applies for detection in detection you
just you don't only want to label you
also want to know the rough location of
that label right so you want a bounding
box so you could say well I want to know
that overlap or you could say after that
overlap has been met then I want to know
my precision am I am I recall and with
segmentation you do need to measure your
that overlap and another for instance if
you're using tools like this is
important it wants to choose tools that
already give you some evaluations for
instance if you Pascal
you see challenge or Koko challenge
already give you access to two code that
evaluates models for you or that
evaluate predictions for you
so it makes perfect sense to not
reinvent the wheel and make use of that
and there's no excuse really to say well
it's just that I have to eyeball it I
have to look at it because I've got no
metric for it even ganz have metrics now
and I'll be sharing these slides and
there's tons of links in there this is a
link to a survey paper of metrics on
guns so if that's what you're into
there's no excuse for you not to measure
how well you're doing okay so you've got
your tasks you've got your your metric
and you're ready to design your baseline
so what is a baseline then it can be
actually anything if you want to go for
yeah random weights or reporting middle
of the frame all the time there's
nothing there to stop you but the whole
idea is to have a fairly quick to
implement naive approach to make sure
that you're not doing something stupid
investing weeks and weeks and weeks to
get an approach to to make another
implementation that adds nothing because
if you're already good for instance with
the case of the bananas and lemons from
from Friday if you're already getting
way more precision that you need just by
reporting that circles are lemons why on
earth would you want to do something
more complicated just be done with it
you know release ship it you're done in
a week instead of a month that's good
and that's the whole idea so your first
instinct should be to start simple have
a fairly reasonable assumption of some
and implemented easily hopefully measure
it because you've already chosen your
metric right so measure that with that
metric keep that data set that test data
set constant and that's where you be
comparing yourself with okay and that's
not about how we're going to be working
or how usually you you're probably
working there will be a lot of
assumptions a lot of hypotheses
design tweaking and evaluating before
you know it you'll end up with tons and
tons of experiments how you how you
track them is up to you I don't know
about you but I've made my share of
mistakes and there's actually been also
in PI data so you should check the talks
on Friday there was one example I'll get
to that in a second but how you track
those experiments is up to you you can
go from very sophisticated and fantastic
solutions usually commercial that track
everything for you and start multiple
experiments at the same time and then
have your database with all your models
or all your approaches doctor by that
metric that you chose down to well i'm
just outputting custom named files and
and aggregating my my metrics metric
results in a CSV which is already the
minimum you should be doing really below
that yeah you don't want to be there huh
it's painful so anywhere in between
there's tons of options and yeah again I
really encourage you to take a look if
you weren't here on Friday I encourage
you to take a look at the talk for about
poly axon there's a does that for you
amongst other things
otherwise there's other free solutions
like FGM lab or model DB that are super
helpful to keep track of your
experiments right ok so you've got your
task you defined it you know how to
measure it and you've actually decided
upon a baseline that you're going to be
comparing everything else against
perfect so let's try to apply this tie
it together in a couple of examples and
the first one can be yeah that that
application looks a very a very simple
application where you've got this this
on the phone you've got a user going
through their Instagram feed they like
they like what they see you take a
snapshot and expect to get links in
return of where exactly to buy those
clothes so is anyone here from well if
there's computer vision people here can
you shout out what problem
you're trying to solve under the hood if
it's detection classification or
something else it's image retrieval it's
it's plain old content-based image
retrieval really you just want to see
what's in the image and try to retrieve
information from it so the way you
describe you're going to be extracting
information from that image you're going
to get a descriptor and you're going to
be sending it and which and getting
something back right you're going to be
finding similar images to what is in to
what's in there sorry see what's in here
but of course the devil is in the
details right so you have like we're
saying at the beginning you need to
start with your constraint so let's say
in a team your manager your supervisor
your your mentor whatever they tell you
look we're going to be dealing with
Instagram we're going to be we need to
keep server costs down because I don't
know where the university or you're a
start-up or you're on your own
and you really need to keep the cost
down so anything that you can run on a
phone is already a world and of course
you don't want to be missing hits
because then you're you're losing money
so and you also don't want to be giving
money to say partners or non partners
right you just wants money to go to
whoever selling the clothes that you
have that you carry and you want money
to go to the influencer that's been
partnering with you so since this is a
very simple case it would be completely
absurd simple in the sense that think
about it you're talking about Instagram
if you've partnered up with those with
those influencers you've know fairly
well what photo shoots have been going
on running so getting something along
the same lines is going to be of nicely
constraint problem so it would be absurd
not to try a traditional technique
because it runs extremely quickly on the
phone and you save your safe cost you
never get to that you never need to
actually go on the server and calculate
things there you don't need to do the
image description there you could also
consider other options
but yeah if you already if you already
have an f1 of zero 97 and say for
instance for the sake of the argument
you receive the assignment of being
above 0 95 in accuracy wouldn't this be
enough would you really want to go
through the whole set up of deep
learning maybe you would I don't know in
my case I would say the learning would
be to start simple to avoid going
through the hassle that is not really
necessary that will not give you extra
value and of course take advantage of
those constraints so study the problem
and see if you can get away with
something simpler and maybe release
something in two months instead of
having to go through the through months
and months of development and tweaking
and evaluating and then finally shipping
another example a bit more complicated I
guess so yeah as you saw I think the
video at the beginning let's say you
want to apply some special effects on
someone and you're going to be doing it
on a phone or on this case is a challah
dance so again you're going to have some
very some some huge oops
there we go you're going to have some
constraints and it pays - it pays to
look at them and be mindful of why
you're going to be deploying or for
instance you have a case where this is
fairly in the world where you have tons
and tons of different sizes people
really far away so it's not anymore a
selfie we're yeah I'm taking a picture
and I'm right here right I'm even again
even reporting center of the frame would
also already be a good approach so if
you want to apply say a filter on all of
those faces you better have a really
nice model that can see really far away
in really small faces so again you start
with the constraints that's unfortunate
let's say for the sake of the argument
that those squares are actually happy
faces
sorry about that so there's our happy
faces so yeah basically you take it you
take a look at the constraints and
something is going to be running on the
phone so deep neural networks it can be
done but it will take some suffering or
as usual traditional techniques are
really nice to it to run you need to be
doing this in real time if you're going
to be applying filters or special
effects you're probably going to have a
unity layer on top so it's not just
being on real time it you do need to to
do better than that so yeah again CNN's
might have a bit of a problem
traditional techniques we'll see usually
it should be a pair these just the speed
itself should be okay with data in the
wild so how are you going to be applying
it in a nicely constrained case where
people are you know with a white
background and staring right there or
are people going to be using your your
product while maybe moving around and in
a bar low light facing away just maybe
running being ten meters away or like in
that group selfie again you might have
people that that whose faces are really
really tiny that's kind of the
definition of in the wall you don't
really know what to expect and their
traditional techniques I don't know
where as CNN's should depending on the
data you choose to train should be okay
and for both of them since you're going
to be dealing with RGB then that's not
really a constraint you're free to use
whichever approach so what kind of tasks
are you are you doing here we've been
talking a lot about detector so yes
boiler it is a detection problem where
you you want to know the location and
you want to know the rough size of your
target to be applying things like yeah
that fire effect so we're going to be
true are we're going to be using
precision what about the baseline well
since there's already an open CV plugin
for unity and since after all
computer vision has been doing face and
people
detection for a long long time and it
has been state-of-the-art until fairly
recently it would be a bit dumb not to
try it out I guess it's right there it
should be easy to set up right so let's
say you go with that and you design your
baseline you say well I'm going to be
using cascade detectors for instance and
I'm going to be and I know I've got the
profile and a gov I've got my front the
one specialist on front hold and I've
got the the ones specialised in heads
and shoulders so I'm going to trial of
that I'm going to tweak them not too
long but you know enough to have it
reasonable and I'll go with that let's
see and after some some little tweaking
and deploying it you choose your data
set you measure and yeah maybe not
because after all your test data was
trying to be realistic so you you were
you had people at very different
distances and doing all sorts of weird
things and yeah maybe not
plus it wasn't so fast anyway if you
want to do real time you should really
be aiming at something at least 25 fps
and if you have other layers on top you
should really be aiming at something
like 30 40 so yeah not gonna work so
again back to the back to the the the
blackboard and you're going to have to
think about your constraints so again
those black boxes are actually smiley
faces and we were suffering about
deploying on a phone we were suffering
about deploying and being able to run
this in real time and we're not so
concerned about data so what do you do
when your main concern is actually the
hardware in your specs I'm not going to
go into too much detail here I'm going
to I guess I'm going to be click baiting
you there is a talk last year about this
exact case and what we did when we saw
that computer vision was failing us and
we had to apply deep learning so this is
a real case that you can check from PI
data 2017 but basically what you do in
is okay let's look for a detection
architecture that is light and fast and
has a fairly good accuracy and since you
have your constraints and you need how
fast it has to be and you and you know
how much memory you need to use you can
already filter out quite a few
architectures right so you can think of
just implementing those so again the
cycle of designing tweaking the hell out
of it and evaluating and comparing
against that baseline and you could
maybe end up with something like this
this is ballpark figures but it's fairly
reasonable where you would have measured
your speed because you have a very hard
constraining speed and you're also also
measuring your average position because
you care about how you know how the
quality of your predictions right and it
turns out that is much much better than
your baseline so definitely you still
need to tweak and use and you want to be
deploying and making a whole continuous
delivery system around that approach the
deep learning approach not the computer
vision but you wouldn't have known you
wouldn't have been sure if you hadn't
started off with a baseline and I just
like to make a final note oh I've got a
couple of minutes left so just about how
these things usually go because it's not
it's not an exact science so you always
you always have that out should we go
compare traditional computation should
we go deep learning as time goes by
probably your baseline will already be
something like a pre trained model right
eventually those concerns about hardware
will not make much sense because we're
not we're not going to be some so
limited formats and deployment libraries
will not have so much can have so many
constraints you will be able to deploy
anything that you're able to train so
it's just this transition time where you
need to be very mindful but today we're
still in this in a situation where you
need to think okay how am I going to to
use my resources how much time do I
devote into working on that baseline
that I'm that might take me far enough
or not I'm not sure should I already
start working on that deep
approach so first you're going to be
probably going to want most people
working on that baseline that you hope
will be enough and we hope is going to
be the only solution we're well and at
the same time have maybe someone still
looking into into doing survey work
looking at papers seeing what's out
there seeing what people have already
been able to deploy at some point you
really want to define what metrics
you're going to be using how you're
going to be making your decision what
metric what dataset what you what's your
your test data are going to be and
making sure it's extremely similar as
similar as you can get to your real use
case and at some point in time hopefully
very quickly you're going to to to
confront both of them you're going to be
measuring your baseline you're going to
be measuring a first naive approach of a
deep learning solution and infant
happens like in in in the in the example
before you realize that no matter how
much you tweak that that computer vision
approach it's not going to be good
enough so you're better off cutting that
and moving everyone to to work on the
deep learning approach so yeah recapping
everything in a nutshell
what I would do starting right now is
always be mindful of constraints I would
always be thinking about okay
what am I being asked really can I get
away with something sit with something
simple it's always about getting away
with things right it's about how I want
to be things very simple but not so
simple that nobody wants to use it I
don't want to waste time gaining that
extra point 1% like in the papers but I
do want things to be good enough for
people to use so what are my real
constraints do I have to be deploying in
the real time to have to be do I have to
support any imaginable case or do I
really know that under the hood people
are going to be using my product in a
really nicely contained space where I
don't need to plan for everything like
in that Instagram case is my problem
really in the wild do I have to support
any kind of picture
anywhere or am I really in a nice little
box where I can get away with something
nice simple and fun to use
you need second step would be okay what
since I know with a test that I know my
constraint now what tasks do I need to
solve what machine learning or computer
vision problem I'm a really solving is a
classification that image retrieval is
tracking what is it and what metrics do
people use to measure this and last of
all well at this last of the preparation
part decide on a baseline get it
measured and yeah that's your that's a
good start yep thank you and if you've
got any comments or you want to tell me
how you guys do it keep in touch
[Applause]
questions
hello and thank you for the presentation
I have a question about the the baseline
and there sorry the model that probably
complex model that you want to create
right
imagine you create a baseline very
simple very fast with 95 percent right
how is possible to estimate the complex
model accuracy before you implement it
right you wouldn't you wouldn't estimate
it really you would you you if the
baseline is already matching your
expectations you can stop there
not in research in research of course
you want to go as far as you can
possibly can but if you if you're told
we need to deliver to get the next
investment round in a month and your
baseline is already good enough you
shape the baseline and you don't think
but about there I mean the goodness of
the accuracy right least 95 90 there
isn't no such as exact answer for that's
right it depend on the complexity of
your model or your problem right sure if
you want to later on work on it because
you get additional constraints and you
want to start working on on that other
then you report that but that's after
you've you've built it because you want
to try it out because you're not very
sure because you think right that was
good for this first release but it's not
going to take us two years so but at the
very beginning if you really so it
depends on the time constraint right if
you really need to ship something and
the baseline is already good enough you
ship that if not you carry on working
and you have to push the deadline but
the thing is that is ship something that
is good enough and then you don't really
estimate you don't think about it you
start thinking about it when you realize
that your baseline is not good enough
and so you mentioned two things one is
the importance of measuring and in the
beginning kind of the lack of label data
that we usually face which makes it hard
to measure how do you reconcile the two
so if we lacked label data it's hard to
measure on things right yeah yeah it's
that's it is hard so when you've got a
very that you're talking about that very
limited so when you've got very limited
data how are you even going to divide
that so that you can train on something
and test on something there is different
schools I personally prefer to save as
much as I can for testing and try to
augment the data I have for training at
least in images I'm not sure about other
disciplines and images it's fairly easy
or least is feasible to augment the data
that you have to get a proper training
set and then reserve as much as you can
from the real data for your evaluation
so that's what I usually do not sure if
that's the best approach but yeah it
works for me thank you that's question
all right so go to your next rooms thank
you thank you
[Applause]